evènement donc quatre chefs piqué
deuxième rubrique la partie commentée de
la semaine et troisième rubrique bien
entendu consacré au nouvel international
donc plein zoom sur le premier événement
premier rubrique l'événement de la
semaine le match piquette quatre chefs
donc alors à cannes
les matches ne sont visiblement font
font partie de pas d'un quotidien mais
son sont aujourd'hui devenus éléments
comment dire l'aimant habituel on est
habitué à voir donc d'aider max
fréquemment notamment avec quatre chefs
alors donc un match 4 chefs piquer un
match qui pour lequel on attend beaucoup
quatre chefs dont comme on a vu très
récemment au tournoi de bordeaux alors
un match pourquoi un match qu'elle
quelle est la différence notable qu'il
peut y avoir entre un match et un
tournoi oui alors il ya donc il ya déjà
il ya plusieurs types d'événements aux
échecs il ya les tournois les délais
tournoi open avec si son joueur ou 1000
joueurs ou de son joueur plus
modestement ce genre de tournoi donc
neuf rondes on sait pas trop qui ont
rencontré une sorte de loterie
échiquéenne puisque on peut bénéficier
d'un apparemment favorables à la
dernière ronde gagné la partie ainsi se
retrouve propulsé en haut du classement
alors qu'on ne le méritait pas et
inversement
ça c'est les tournois open il yal et ont
affirmé qu'ils sont plus justes déjà ses
terres dix joueurs chacun va jouer
contre les autres et finalement donc
ultime spécifications dirait et ultime
étape de la de la spécialisation c'est
le match le match c'est un joueur contre
un joueur qui s'affrontent dans
plusieurs parties
alors toi qui es un joueur professionnel
quelle est la différence qui peut y
avoir entre une préparation d'un tournoi
dont couvert d'un canopen et d'un match
comme celui qu'on veut qu'on vit
actuellement à cannes alors pour un open
on travaille d'abord son propre jeu
avant tout c'est à dire que nous sommes
la base de la préparation on essaie de
corriger nos faiblesses on s'informe sur
les nouveautés de notre propre
répertoire d'ouvertures
ça c'est la première le premier point
dans un tournoi fermé
c'est dire qu'on connaît à l'avancé la
liste des neuf adversaires qu'on va
rencontrer dès 9hoo des douze des quinze
donc là on se prépare sur eux c'est à
dire on regarde brièvement ce que je
voulais 15 joueurs on s'adapte un petit
peu et on y va pour un match alors là on
se prépare uniquement sur l'autre
c'est à dire on fait des analogies entre
ce que nous jouons nous est ce que je
vaux notre adversaire et la préparation
est donc hyper cibler très ciblés dans
un match dans un match c'est normal
alors pour nos amis qui suivent
actuellement le direct je tiens à
rappeler que le maître international
jean luc chabanon est actuellement donc
sur le tchad donc vous pouvez poser
toutes les questions que vous voulez il
est là pour pour y répondre
donc en ce qui concerne quatre chefs bon
on a vu un match contre van der wiel
gadget n'est pas à son premier match à
cannes comment dire est-ce qu'on a
l'impression que que gladys lave prépare
quelque chose peut-être de plus
important de l'impression que les
matches entre en amplitude
oui oui c'est le troisième match de
vladislav tkachiev à cannes son premier
adversaire étant alberto david lowe
grand maître luxembourgeois qu'il avait
entre dans une certaine mesure explosé
puisqu'il avait gagné je sais plus cinq
et demi deux ans et demi je crois ce qui
était un score considérable deuxième
match contre a priori plus fort john van
der wiel le fameux boucher hollandais
dont on a beaucoup parlé dans diagonale
et donc la match contre j'ai une
piquette extrêmement fort le meilleur
joueur hollandais qui à 2650 récemment
il a battu garry kasparov au grand prix
kasparov d'ailleurs en finale donc la
gagner ce tournoi il a il vraiment et
c'est l'homme en forme du moment
donc les matchs vont de en croissant de
plus en plus fort là effectivement le
but de vladislav maintenant le but avoué
de devenir clairement un très fort
joueur de match puisque à priori on ne
sait pas où ça s'arrêtera pour l'instant
il a gagné tous ses matches il à la 20e
place mondiale au classement elo donc il
a des ambitions sérieuses d'accord donc
dû dans la première partie nulle
également dans la seconde partie et puis
troisième partie piqué gagne gagne 7,7
troisième manche
alors qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans
la tête d'un joueur
à ce moment du match après avoir eu un
avantage dans la deuxième partie est
perdant la troisième
oui alors ça c'est difficile à c'est une
défaite c'est toujours difficile surtout
que là il avait fait deux nuls n'avait
donc pas gagné deux parties il était
assez proche de la victoire dans cette
deuxième partie qu'on commencera tout à
l'heure et hop il se prend une défaite
assez sévère puisque
à mon avis c'est quand même été dominé
toute la partie donc une défaite
vraiment regrettable difficile à
surmonter sur un plan psychologique ça
ça a dû lui poser des problèmes
maintenant on connaît le résultat la
quatrième partie qui a été jouée
aujourd'hui il est revenu au score il a
gagné une brillante brillante partie
donc ça c'est c'est un bon point pour
lui il a su revenir dans le match ce qui
montre à un certain esprit de
compétition et une volonté très très
fort de gagner 2 et de ne rien rater
finalement oui alors c'est clairement un
très très beau match entre dreux 2
fantastique combattants d'un côté on a
piqué est qui était un ancien espoir
vraiment ancien espoir
il est toujours extrêmement fort mais on
le voyait vraiment arriver à la place de
kasparov
de l'autre côté on a cet inconnu
vladislav tkachiev qui s'est révélé vers
l'âge de 20 ans 21 ans que personne
n'avait jamais vu nulle part donc un
très beau match de style un peu un peu
dit je dirais qu'ils se ressemblent et
ça donne des partis assez explosive
assez violente et une grosse combativité
grosse combativité ça c'est vraiment ce
qu'on peut dire un point commun dans le
style et de joie c'est quelque part un
point commun avec les échecs spectacle
alors on a on a connu donc dans les
années passées il y a pas mal d'années
maintenant certaine excentricité au
travers de
deux matchs notamment des matches de
championnat du monde c'est quelque chose
qu'on rencontre un peu moins par exemple
des port de lunettes noires je
reviendrai pas sur ces anecdotes assez
amusante mais c'est vrai que ces
derniers temps en impression que les
échecs il devenu vraiment très sérieux
les matches sont très bien organisés ils
y a tout est parfait et les joueurs sont
quelque part on a l'impression qu'ils
sont plus professionnels
disons qu'ils sont passés d'un statut de
politique un statut économique
voilà on va formuler ça comme ça avant
c'était le bloc est ouest s'était
fischer qui il y avait des enjeux une
pression tellement terrible sur le match
est toute l'union soviétique qui
allaient s'acharner sur un joueur qui
allait perdre un match
c'était terrible terrible pour ces
joueurs il y avait une pression
tellement énorme que ça dépasse
l'entendement humain nécessaire qu'ils
étaient prêts à faire n'importe quoi à
se plaindre de n'importe quoi alors que
maintenant on est entré dans une phase
où c'est plus des échecs commerciaux
entre guillemets c'est dire que les
joueurs ont une image à respecter
veulent développer un jeu d'échec ils
ont des idées quand même assez saine
lors idc c'est simplement que tout aille
mieux quand les échecs soit mis en
spectacle et ça ça passe quand même par
une bonne présentation une bonne tenue
des réponses aux journalistes qui avant
était quasiment inexistante enfin des
déclarations elle était très brève
maintenance et on n'arrive plus vert
vers la médiatisation du jeu d'échecs et
donc ça c'est la raison principale pour
laquelle il ya moins de scandale je sais
pas si d'ailleurs c'est un scandale est
bon pour la presse ou pas ça c'est un
sujet à débattre en tout cas maintenant
les joueurs sont plus cool
et donc la médiatisation du jeu et a
priori meilleurs d'accord donc les
échecs spectacle les échecs au profit de
donc de la personne qui va regarder le
match aujourd'hui on se tourne vers
vraiment vers le vert
les spectateurs très bien en ce qui
concerne la psychologie la psychologie
en mach at elle vraiment un rôle très
important
la psychologie en match c'est plus
important je dirais qu'en tournoi
puisque en tournoi on va jouer un
adversaire qu'on ne connaît pas le
lendemain un adversaire nouveau dans un
match il ya shirov qui racontait sa
alexei shirov non c'était vladimir
kramnik puisque shirov a vraiment un
gros spécialistes des matches vladimir
kramnik il dit mais moi je n'en peux
plus au bout de trois jours avoir encore
la même tête en face de moi c'est très
difficile c'est impossible
alors effectivement il ya des joueurs
qui sont sensibles à ce genre de choses
c'est à dire avoir toujours les joueurs
jouer des ouvertures qui se ressemblent
des partis qui se ressemblent toujours
se braquer sur un même objectif
ça c'est difficile ça c'est assez
difficile c'est une mentalité
particulière
maintenant il ya la mentalité des
joueurs de tournois qui eux sont plus
cools sont plus tranquilles qui se
focalise moins qu'ils veulent voir
différentes ouvertures et ça c'est un
autre aspect c'est un autre une autre
psychologie qui est différente qui est
moins je dirais moins spécialisés mois
moins rigoureuses donc la psychologie en
match est vraiment très importante déjà
sur soi et en plus au niveau de
l'adversaire tout simplement il faut
bien comprendre ce qu'il veut jouer ce
que tu dis là est très important car
quand on voit le nombre de partis qui
ont pu discuter ensemble karpov et
kasparov plusieurs centaines de parties
effectivement l'aspect psychologique est
à mon avis un aspect fondamental ça doit
pas être évident à la longue de tenir
une si longue distance 10 mois et loi je
crois que ce soir on a quelque chose
d'un peu particulier on va recevoir donc
par conversation téléphonique
ladislav quatre chefs qui va donc nous
donner ses commentaires sur la quatrième
partie sur son bien sur son état
d'esprit dans le match qui le kilo pose
donc agir olympique hé oui alors il a
dit cela parce que tu es la balade à
l'eau oui donc là nous avons jean-luc
chavanon a priori
bonjour effet jean-luc donc en direct de
l'abstraction de cannes
et donc voilà je vais vous laisser blad
a tout de suite
oui alors apparemment il ya une coupure
donc la technologie
la technologie n'est pas toujours au
point jean luc est ce que tu nous
entends ou est-ce que c'est van kim
alors jean-luc oui oui est ce que tu
peux nous passer vladislav tkachiev halo
vlad
alors donc tu es revenu dans ce match ne
gagnez une brise en deux parties dans la
quatrième est-ce que c'était difficile
après la défaite d'hier de revenir
meilleur donc je pense que je fais
partie très tendue au point que c'est ce
qui est intéressant c'est le type ou
parce que son couteau plein nouveau donc
c'était une grosse surprise pour moi et
je pense que je me débrouille bien et
maillard abandonné il m'a formé et me
semble je veux pour la news me sens des
suppliciés la position mais j'essaie
quand même de devenir la tension est
donc et finalement je m'occupe remplit
très bien d'accord donc et le soir tu as
bien dormi que tu as aussi revenir en
pleine forme aujourd'hui et tues et a
gagné une très belle victoire a ajouté
je pense que donc elle m'a beaucoup
impressionné avec son tweet je pense que
tu piques demain l hp ne serait plus
beau est parti aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment très très belle et je pense qu
il m'a dominé la plupart que les partis
mais puis à se retrouver tous les deux
dans un trou va être notre âme un
barrage devant vingt dix minutes on a eu
que dix minutes pour tous les deux ans
le groupe a donc peut-être vraiment très
très difficile qui conduit que moi m'a
finalement intrigué louis kiehl fait
tremper est bon et je gagnais à l'eau
oui oui d'accord donc que bon bah bravo
en tout cas pour cette victoire alors
avec nicolas on se posait une question
mettez vos valeurs
oui allô place issaaf oui oui on a
encore une question on se posait une
question avec nicolas laval est à côté
de moi c'est cette tradition des matches
à cannes
est-ce que c'est pas pour aller vers une
sorte de match championnat du monde
contre le garry kasparov donc là c'est
jean-luc chavanon que nous avons il fait
partie des possibilités donc des choses
qu'on pourrait organiser donc la dette
de plus en plus en forme quoi dis donc
et actuellement il a commencé par john
devant alberto david il a joué contre
john van der wiel
bon là il retrouve l contre y aurait de
piquette et peut-être que dans un procès
un match qui pourrait jouer encore une
gestion encore plus fort et peut-être
dans quelques années dans deux trois
rencontres bulgarie 14 mais je pense que
vlad a pas envie d'attendre avant de
jouer un match pareil car c'est quelque
chose qui demande beaucoup de
préparation alors jean-luc donc tu es là
bas à cannes fait une autre
correspondance spéciale
telle est l'ambiance de ce match parce
que les joueurs sont attendus ou plutôt
décontracté il ya une ambiance très
tendue
je dois dire que donc le match et
grandir très très équilibré les joueurs
se respectent beaucoup et donc qui s'est
passé c'est que donc après sa défaite
donc hier contre piquette vlad avait
vraiment besoin petit peu de prendre
l'air et donc il est il a été il était
en ville parce que tu es ou faut dire
quand même que très très bel hôtel mais
qui a un peu isolé donc il a été en vie
un petit peu hier en soirée et
finalement un petit peu pour se détendre
et et parce qu'il allait plus besoin de
préparation il a beaucoup de travail et
de match avec son second temps on leur
tape deux griefs qui est un joueur
casaque de très grands très très fort
grand maître et donc j'aimerais qu'ils
avaient vraiment besoin de se détendre
un petit peu à quoi d'accord voit bien
jean-luc on vous remercie pour cette
interview
on rappelle aux spectateurs qui peuvent
rentrer jean-luc chavanon sur le tchad
dont qui est actuellement avec vanille
stade catch elle donc si vous avez des
questions à leur poser
allez-y ils sont en direct sur le chat
sur canal web profiter
profitez-en l'a dit cela fait jean-luc
chavanon en même temps sur le chat c'est
pas quelque chose de courant alors
profitez-en ils sont là donc pour
répondre à vos questions
bien et loi je te propose maintenant
donc
bien d'analyser ensemble la 2 et
deuxième parties donc du match donc
quatre chefs piqué donc une partie qui
s'est soldée par la nulle mais une
partie très intéressante parce que très
très très tendue donc je te propose de
regarder cette partie tout de suite oui
même si c'est la deuxième partie du
match
rappelons que le score du match
actuellement et de partout puisqu'il ya
eu deux nuls
un gain et une défaite pour chacun des
joueurs là c'était un peu je dirais le
ronde
2 un peu l'échauffement un peu la prise
de mesures les joueurs étaient pas
encore très très chaud et pourtant ça va
me donner une partie assez explosive
donc vladislav à les blancs et ils
ouvrent par son coup favori en ce moment
qui est le coût des quatre en ce moment
il ne joue pratiquement que ça il a
oublié
on dirait qu'il a oublié l'existence du
coup un vieux 4 donc il ajouté de
descartes il l'a joué énormément donc
dans le passé le coup eux quatre oui
c'était son son court fétiche disons
qu'il ne jouait que quatre avant avec
des systèmes un peu biaisé eux contre
les sicilienne décidé de fermer des
céciliennes un peu ailleurs
un peu à la dame voilà un peu un style
anglais disons ce qui est surprenant
pour un joueur kazakh
ici il joue des 4 maintenant ils vident
joue principalement ce coup là un des
quatre des cinq donc la pique est très
solide toujours au après le coup deux c4
il répond pas c'est si ce qui est donc
la défense slave
c'est a priori ni des forces là c'est à
dire qu'on joue sur les cases blanches
on essaie de tenir des cases blanches
donc des cinq essais si si si en
attendant un peu de voir ce qui va se
passer
donc là visiblement les les noirs
pourraient prendre le pion c4 les noirs
auraient pu le prendre
aurait pu prendre coude avant ça aurait
été un grand vide à m'accepter c'est à
dire dans cette position là je vous ai
dépensé 4 c'est possible ça rentre dans
une variante du grand vide à m'accepter
de toute façon et blanc par la force des
choses c'est à dire par d une séquence
de courant connu récupère le pion ils
vont reprendre le cuir dans ses cales
donc en fait c'est un pseudo sacrifice
de pions l'option n'est pas vraiment aux
prises ici
donc après donc ces quatre c6 kbc 3 au
troisième coup des blancs cavalia 6 on
est toujours dans la défense slave est
ici vlad choisi le coût 4 3 qui est qui
s'avance que je dirais vers levante 2 0
alors c'est un coût qui est un peu
particulier parce que quand je regarde
cette position là j'ai l'impression que
le coup ans
le pied en e3 vient bloquer le fou qui
est en c1 c'est un pot qui semble pas
très très naturel tout à fait
effectivement le fou ne peut plus sortir
sur la case où on a envie de la mettre
qui est la 4g 5
mais il ya d'autres problèmes dans cette
ouverture des conceptions complexe à
base de la prise justement de se fiancer
4 qui nous pousse à donner une priorité
à la défense du fiancé 4 c'est à dire
que maintenant le fouet fin des fonds en
l'occurrence et 4 donc ici plus de
problème avec ce pion on joue à trois
effectivement on ferme les possibilités
de sortie du four en c1 le fou qui est
en verre ici mais il sortira plus tard
déjà
ou alors sortir sur un autre chemin on
peut aussi envisager de le mettre sur la
case amphion kétou en fait tout
simplement jambes et trois foulées d'olt
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est une
sorte de position quelque peu ressort ou
dans le dans le sens où les blancs
finalement se détendent pas tout de
suite et c'est donc d'abord de serrer le
jeu de prendre un petit avantage puis
ensuite éventuellement de pousser le
pion 3 vers l'aspect cas centrale de 4
oui ça c'est l'idée à long terme c'est à
dire que des fois on sort le fou en b2
d'abord et après on joue à quatre mais
enfin dans un premier temps les blancs
connaissent bien les principes de
l'ouverture rappelons quand même que le
principe de base de l'ouverture après
avoir pris le centre c'est dernis et
puis en centre il faut développer ces
pièces mineurs les fous et les cavaliers
et très vite jouée le petit rock donc
ici les blancs se concentre d'abord sur
le développement et ensuite prendre le
centre avec le 3 e 4 donc côté noir
pareil on ferme la diagonale du fou de
cases blanches c'est à dire que le fou
s'est vite ne sortira plus maintenant
sur cette grande diagonale j'anticipais
question peut-être
voilà c'est vrai mais les noirs ont le
même objectif que les blancs on avait
l'impression vraiment que les deux camps
restent dans leur camp justement oui
tout à fait donc là c'est ça sa annonce
un peu une sorte de guerre de tranchées
où chacun restera
restera là un petit peu crampes et
derrière les pions mais bon tout ça est
fait pour déplier
j'ai donc l'impression quand je jouais
en d4 et d5 on est vraiment et là je
pense que le spectateur pourra le
constater dans une position ferme et
nous sommes dans une posture ferme ici
clairement ça change des grosses
d'ouverture ouverte tout à fait donc
cavalier f3 normal développement
développement développement pareil pour
les noirs cavale et b17 là on peut dire
que ça bloque le fou mais le fou étaient
déjà bloqués donc ici pas de pas de
soucis au niveau du développement on
sait très bien comment ça va se finir
les blancs vont sortir leur foute cases
blanches les noirs vont sortir beaucoup
de cases noires et les camps vont roke a
priori ça devrait être ça la suite
normale donc les blanches ou six fou en
d3 foire des trois cc oui c'est un pôle
de développement logique on peut se
poser la question sur la prise du pion
c4 par les noirs puisque à ce moment là
on pourrait presque penser que les
blancs ont perdu un temps oui
effectivement alors principe très
important dans l'ouverture et c'est de
ne pas perdre de temps c'est à dire ne
pas jouer deux fois avec la même pièce
effectivement le couple français 4 c'est
la partie qui a été joué donc c'est une
possibilité ici l'autre possibilité est
de jouer fois fuite en d6 ça existe
également pions france les caps c'est un
peu une tentative d'utiliser ce
développement prématuré du fou puisque
l'autre ou qui auraient été possibles
pour les blancs aurait été de sortir la
dame d'abord c'est à dire attendre un
petit peu pour sortir ce fou c'est à
dire réservés empêcher les noirs de
prononcer 4 s'est empêché de gagner du
temps pendant sur s'éclate d'accord donc
temporiser forçant par là même la prise
ce qui a abandonné les noirs vont bien
devoir jouer leurs coûts donc forçant la
prise en c4 à ce moment là le fou
pourrait prendre donc sans perdre de
temps
ce faire mes pions c4 oui donc c'est une
autre c'est une autre variante qui est
possible ici ladislav je vous fous des
trois jean françaix 4 il faut penser 4
obligatoires donc quand on a dit là il
faut dire b donc j'ai l'impression que
effectivement les bleus ont perdu un
temps mais quelque part avec une
compensation dans le sens pour les
blancs dans le sens où
en les quatre centrales vont être prises
par les blancs visiblement je vois un
trou en dents sur la case des 5 et 6 les
blancs peuvent pousser le pion au no 4
ça va être prochainement les blancs au
centre et les blancs vont
indiscutablement installer un duo de
pion central a eu quatre décades si
possible donc là effectivement les noirs
ont fait une concession mais pour ça ils
ont ils ont une entière une arme secrète
ils ont ils ont une idée derrière la
tête
dire que la cij chacun des deux camps
devaient jouer dix coups c'est à dire si
on prenait la position dans le long
terme
les blancs seraient mieux c'est clair
ils ont le centre iso un avantage
durable sur le long terme
mais ce qu'il faut voir c'est que là les
noirs jouent le coup de behcet b5 et là
c'est quelque part le ressort qui se
détend ça commence à se détendre c'est à
dire que là ils arrivent ils gagnent
encore du temps c'est à dire que la
indiscutablement en option des cinq
attaques le fond il n'y a pas de pas de
mystère là dessus donc le foot doit
bouger encore le four par en d3 et
maintenant ça me permet de nous
développer avec fougue et cette tutu
m'arrêtera et voici si je dis une bêtise
mais j'ai l'impression que ce genre de
défense fait comme on dire vraiment
partie de ce qu'on appelle les échecs
moderne dans le sens où les noirs
moi aussi d'avoir une position dynamique
même si cela entraîne un défaut
structurel de pion dans la position
oui on peut dire ça on peut dire que les
noirs cherche en fait à gagner
pas du potentiel puisque c'est le
potentiel et côté blanc ici mais en fait
à déstabiliser les blancs ils veulent
jouer rapidement ici très rapidement
après voir mon le coup c6 c5 qui sera
parfait puisque une fois que le pion se
rend ces 5
le fourbe et 7 sera sur la grande
diagonale la grande diagonale c'est la
plus longue de l'échiquier y en a deux
donc là le fourbe et 7 rassure sa grande
diagonale propre et puis le pion est un
pion à virer si je pense moins pour
l'instant l'option celle ci c'est
arriérés donc ils demandent qu'à avancer
sa attaquera le centre en plus
s'attaquera pions des quatre tiers
s'échangera un pion qui est un peu sur
le côté contre un pion central ce qui
sera très bon et en plus toutes les
pièces noires seront sortis donc là les
noirs cherche absolument à jouer c6 c5
et là c'est l'enjeu de cette position
effectivement s'il est blanc arrive à
bloquer la casse c5 c6 s'il arrive à
jouer pas en b2b 4 et installer une
pièce sur cette case c5
ça va être fini les noirs sont perdants
puisque le fou 17 ne ressortira plus de
la partie en revanche si les noirs
arrivent à jouer c6 c5
ce qui est probable puisque apparemment
ils ont sorti plus de pièces donc ils
vont probablement y arriver c'est de
leur côté de l'échiquier faut pas
oublier ça là ça va être tendu ça va
être équilibré ça va donner une position
d'ici ce qu'on appelle un coup
libérateur un coup libérateur le coup
libérateur et 6 et c6 c5 petit rock pour
les blancs donc pour l'instant on
remarque quand même que c6 c5
immédiatement n'est pas possible puisque
le pion des cinq soirées emprise deux
fois et par le cavalier et par le fonds
qui donc
donc là il faut protéger le pion d'une
manière ou d'une autre avant de pouvoir
pousser ses 5
oui et ici il a trouvé un moyen original
de le protéger c'est à dire qu'il l'a
avancé
en fait dans cette position donc on est
au 9e coup on peut jouer le coup b5 b4
l'option disparaît et en plus on gagne
encore du temps puisque on attaque le
cavalier en c3 donc ça c'est plutôt pas
mal non plus cavalier très logiquement
donc là
principe sauf dans les ouvertures quand
vous ne savez pas quoi faire des pièces
aller toujours vers le son si vous
hésitez entre deux cases plus cette
centrale mieux c'est surtout pour un
cavalier qui est une pièce à courte
distance
surtout pour un cavalier le cavalier
dont vient donc en 4 très logiquement
fawcett est ici donc apparemment tout à
l'air parfait dans la mesure où les
noirs peuvent jouer c7 c6 c5 quand ils
le veulent donc ici ça a l'air plutôt
pas mal et là les blancs jouent un coup
moderne je dirais un coup assez moderne
il jouait le coup pas deux à trois c'est
un coût qui a paru il ya pas si
longtemps que ça dans la théorie sada de
2 3 ans à peu près donc comme d'habitude
dans des donald chaque fois qu'on
commente une partie on vous commente
longuement le début alors que c'est tout
est déjà très connu
cette position a déjà été joué des
centaines de fois c'est ce qu'on appelle
une table hier une table hier on peut
dire salat à bias et un terme russe qui
veut dire une sorte de nouvelles
positions de départ une position on se
met automatiquement pour commencer les
parties donc c'était la méthode
d'entraînement russe en fait au lieu de
commencer avec les veaux cette pièce se
placer sur leur cachet initial ont
commencé avec eux par exemple avec cette
position c'est une étude une approche
par système
oui on évite tout à fait c'est
exactement ça donc dans cette position
les blancs vont attaque le pion quitte
en quittant b4 on peut quand même se
poser la question le pion bekkat était
un pion trêve ans très avancé quelque
part un pion faible et donc on aurait pu
essayer de le bloquer pour essayer de
l'attaqué par d'autres moyens est
finalement là on décide de les changer
pour augmenter la dynamique des pièces
blanches pour augmenter la dynamique des
pièces manche notamment pour sortir ce
fou c'est un sas est une des objections
puisque pour l'instant il ne pouvait pas
sortir
deuxième objectif faire jouer la tour 1
c'est à dire essayer d'ouvrir cette
colonne
à qui est intéressante pour la tour ça
c'est des deux objectifs et autre chose
sauf sur b4 et un peu ennuyeux
puisqu'ils contrôlent la casse et 3 une
case de prime assez avancé dans le camp
des blancs qui vaut il faut pas oublier
ce point là qui est très important donc
on préfère l'échangé l'option a déjà
avancé deux fois nous on avance notions
une fois et on les change au niveau
temporel
on a fait une affaire je dirais c'est
très clair donc ici cavaliers prend 2,4
fou prend 1,4 là on assiste à un échange
suivie d'un point intermédiaire qu'elle
et 17 ans m6 donc là on a échangé les
kabyles centraux et ensuite on se met à
chasser le fou donc
foudre une fois de plus reculer et donc
là on en est quand même au premier
deuxième troisième quatrième cinquième
coup de fouet en 12 coupes et blanche de
sainte foy à leur [ __ ] cases blanches
en douze coups c'est vrai que je
comprends tout à fait le coup des des
noirs il était un petit peu étriqué il y
avait deux cavaliers très proches l'un
de l'autre ils ont essayé de de quelque
part de soulager leurs positions en
échangeant une pièce et puis maintenant
il redéveloppe le cavalier sur une
meilleure casse tout henry attaquant le
fou voilà c'est exactement ça c'est tout
à fait ça ils ont échangé une pièce
centrale des blancs le foot doit
repartir et leur part
maintenant on joue plus on prend pions
puis on prend pions et ici tout
simplement petit rock c'est l'heure de
mettre le roi à l'abri donc là nouveau
bilan puisque on peut voir que les deux
camps ont complété leur développement
ont fait en tout cas on roque est très
important maintenant la pause l'écart
d'opposition se joue entre les pions
c'est contre l'option c6 donc
contribution dé 4 ce qui est intéressant
dans dans une partie fermée telle que
celle là c'est que justement on a pu
voir une pièce jouée trois fois voire
quatre fois et est finalement une
position ferme et c'est pas grave on
joue ça dans une position ouverte c'est
dramatique
oui ferme et finalement on peut se
permettre oui et on dit que dans les
positions fermes et il ya beaucoup plus
de place pour les manoeuvres à long
terme c'est à dire prendre un cavalier
qui est en bas à gauche et l'amener en
haut à droite même si ça prend 10 coups
ça sera pas une catastrophe puisque le
cahier sera sur l'action en fait quand
c'est fermé
on est obligé de tourette des trajets
longs puisque justement ya pas de cases
disponibles des manoeuvres louvoyante
des manoeuvres louvoyante est donc très
très longue
effectivement alors que dans une
position ouverte on n'a pas le temps de
prendre un cavalier d'ici pour l'amener
là bas tout simplement parce que la dame
lefebvre ont un coût donc là on n'a pas
de temps à perdre alors si on fait un
petit bilan de cette position finalement
le pion qui pensaient 6 n'a toujours pas
pu être joué en c5 l'option n'a pas
encore été jouée en c5
mais a priori qu'est-ce qui va
l'empêcher d'y aller pour l'instant on
n'est pas trop capable de dire ce qui va
empêcher ces six d'avancé 5
pourquoi et bien parce que la colonne
s'est pour l'instant n'est pas
accessible par l'ate warin puisqu'il ya
le fou devant donc nul doute que sur le
coup par exemple poussé en b2 ou en p2c
terre si ce fou bouge très vite on joue
ses fils ses cinq et on a réussi à
sortir nos pièces et actuellement nous
sommes toujours
dans la théorie on est toujours dans la
théorie oui oui tout à fait donc ici
tourbe et un attaque le fou donc là en
fait les blancs sont en train de gagner
du temps ils sortent leur tour pour
l'instant donc pas de ses fils est sain
puisque le fou bessette est en prise
c'est un petit peu l'idée du coup à 2 à
3 c pouvoir justement donner de l'air à
la tour il fallait ouvrir une colonne
une des deux colonnes c'était parfait
ils ont ouvert la colonne b il en
profite tout de suite dame s'est vite et
maintenant c'est superbe ce qui va se
passer c'est à dire que les deux les
deux camps les blancs et les noirs vont
faire ce qu'il voulait faire depuis le
début en même temps donc les blancs
jouent eux 4 prenant le sentent et les
noirs jouent ces cinq donc là ça explose
complètement c'est assez incroyable on
aura dû attendre 15 coups avant de voir
les manoeuvres libératrice
de part et d'autre oui c'est à dire que
c'est en fait son quatrième coup que les
blancs jouent eux 2 3 avec déjà l'idée
d'avancer le plan car trop 15e coup au
15e l'essonne se réalise qu'au 15e coup
et voir voire même encore pire pour les
noirs puisqu'ils ont joué ces six au
deuxième coup pour jouer ces cinq
également au 16e coup donc ici voilà des
lectorats long terme se croisent et
c'est là que ça devient très très
compliqué très compliqué pour quoi tout
simplement parce que là il ya de la
tension en cas des changes
mettons deux des pions c et d si le pion
blanc restent en hausse de 4 les noirs
sont mieux pourquoi parce que justement
le foot est roi va se retrouver un peu
sur une colonne ouvertes ainsi que la
dame et ça c'est pas bon c'est pas bon
parce que la meilleure des trois bloqués
par son propre option d'accord et puis
on pourrait installer une tour sur la
tour noire sur la fameuse colonne et
créant éventuellement des menaces très
endettés grosse menace en plus le pion
aux 4 est en prise donc ici ça s'est
passé pas c'est pas une bonne option
d'échanger les pions des essais en tout
cas pas tout de suite et il faut pas non
plus laisser du temps aux cadres donc là
il ya une solution toute trouvée
évidemment que vladislav tkachiev ne
manque pas une job 17e coup le coup e 4
e 5 menace directe sur les reliefs 6
hélas ce qu'il faut dire c'est que dès
que le cavaliere si ce n'est plus là les
dangers d'attaqués rapides sont en train
de se profiler à toute allure
c'est à dire que lecavalier dans cette
position et le défenseur parfait et si
on le chasse effectivement c'est la
porte ouverte à une attaque violente de
la part des blancs c'est vrai quand on
regarde il ya un cavalier il ya deux
fous qui sont braqués sur les droits une
dame qui peut arriver rapidement
donc en fait les les blancs ont
finalement ce sont eux qui en avantage
dynamique là pour l'instant maintenant
les pièces blanches se trouve mieux
placé mais les noirs ont quand même des
atouts dans cette position notamment la
casse des 5 alors ça on va y revenir
cette fameuse case des cinq qui ne peut
plus donc où il ya près de pyongyang qui
peuvent accéder à cette case
donc cette case est totalement ce
contrôle le noir ça c'est le premier
argument
deuxième argument ils ont ici un fou en
bessette qui est pas mal placé du tout
qui est aveugle et qui est même très
très bien placé maintenant donc la voilà
chaque camp a les yeux braqués sur le
roi et demi notamment les blancs ils en
ont deux le noir en ont on est ici le
problème des noirs le gros problème des
noirs c'est que leurs cavaliers
défenseurs principal du petit rock va
devoir partir donc pour faire un petit
bilan sur cette position est ce qu'on
peut dire les pièces venait à s'échanger
que l bien les noirs prendre l avantage
en finale avec justement un pion
avancées telles que tel qu'on peut le
voir en eux 5 en finale dans cette
position je ne sais pas qui al'avantage
a priori ce serait plutôt les noirs ce
serait plutôt les noir jaune et noir
avec un an d'avancé en u15 donc les
blancs doivent tous lancent l attaque
oui c'est à dire qu'en fait la question
de la finale à qui la finale va être
favorable c'est à celui qui a le roi le
moins en sécurité puisque la finale
c'est celle échange des dames
quand on échange les dames ça fait moins
de potentiel l'attaqué une dame c'est
quand même la taxe est quand même très
fort donc ici dès qu'on échange les
dames l'attaqué vachement minimiser très
minimisée
là les noirs n'ont qu'un seul rêve dans
cette position celle échange des ternes
et clairement pour jouer sur la case des
cinq pour commencer à ta question aux
cinq qu'on peut considérer comme trop
avancé
c'est l'objectif des noirs dans cette
question l'objectif des blancs c'est
l'attaqué à tout va on se lance on joue
faux prostate il le faut et on attaque
c'est de bonne augure pour la suite de
la partie c'est de bonne augure pour la
suite de la partie exactement ici
cavalière au 17
donc on peut se poser la question
pourquoi les noirs n'ont pas joué
cavalier f6 en d5 donc ça je pense que
c'est une bonne question c'est vrai que
lecavalier a finalement pu être chantent
super ne peut plus être comment dire
délogée de cette case oui oui le câline
pour appeler déloger mais il ya une
pointe tactique justement dans cette
position c'est que les blancs jour et
d'âme des uns en c2 avec une double
menace c'est à dire qu'on attaque dans
un premier temps le curage cette
fourchette donc ici le coût normal des
noirs et le coup h6 et maintenant
simplement pions prend ses 5 et là on
s'aperçoit que les noirs sont dans une
impasse
pourquoi simplement parce qu'après
france et 5 qui est une faute mais qui
est le coût qui récupère le pion il y
aurait tourbe et un prof ou bessette et
on se retrouverait avec une tour contre
de fou et une tour contre de foot alors
explication rapide dame prend tout
obligatoire réponse obligatoire dame
prend fou et ici les blancs d'oeuf ou
contre une tour ce qui est donc un net
avantage qui est probablement une
position gagnante
donc en fait le cavalier ne pouvait pas
aller sur les caisses des cinq où il
avait envie si on revient dans la
position après 17e coup eux cinq ils
obligés d'aller sur 15 17 pour défendre
le plan c 5 voilà qu'elle est 17
finalement les noirs commencent à
manquer de manoeuvre les noirs les noirs
commencent à manquer d'espacé
effectivement le cavalier pour l'instant
est enfermé un cavalier contre un pion
qui est trois pièces devant on va dire
s'est il est dominé par l'option
puisqu'il peut pas sortir puisque
l'option le prendrais tout simplement
donc là bon mais c'est pas grave puisque
l'option des quatre est amené à
disparaître
grâce à celui qui étend ses 5 mais là
maintenant il ya d une belle attaque qui
se profile toutes les pièces blanches
sont prêtes à y aller et c'est ce que
fait vladislav il lance 18 cavaliers g5
commence à faire des menaces sérieuses
notamment vous propose cet échec
d'accord donc là effectivement le
cavalier les deux fous la reine prête
également à surgir sur sur le roc noir
la position des noirs devient un déviant
difficile en tout cas à l'air d'être
difficile par exemple un coup comme
geste hisserait prononçant actionné par
cavaillé pour 7,8 en maths rapide ici je
pense que pickett a joué pratiquement le
seul cours ou le seul coût raisonnable
dans cette position qui est le coup h 7
h 6 très logique
attaquant le cavalier attaquant le
cavalier très logique donc de la part
des blancs on a presque envie de le
reculer le cavalier en principe on envie
de le reculer mais ici on n'a pas du
tout envie de reculer cavalli cercle
normalement notre conscience va dire le
cavalier temps prises il faut repartir
mais on voudra pas repartir parce que
lecavalier il est trop beau ici à angers
il est complètement dominant il est vert
le roi vers le roi et demi donc on a
absolument pas envie d'enlever mais par
contre il est attaqué donc il faut
trouver une solution donc les blancs en
une petite botte bottes tactique
voilà une petite une petite faim en fait
une passe simplement il joue au 19e coup
la dame en page 5
alors évidemment ici pions prend
cavaliers serait sanctionné par serait
méchamment sanctionné par dame âge
s'encouragent cet échec et mat tout
simplement puisque le rwanda plus de
cases et la dame est défendue par le fou
des trois donc le cavalier finalement ne
peut pas être pris sauf peut-être par le
fou voilà et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est
indispensable puisqu'il commence à y
avoir des menaces assez violente
je pense notamment à foisches cet échec
suivi peut-être parquet les problèmes 7
ou ou par exemple la tour qui est
montrée en d3 enfin en tout cas ici
il ya toutes les raisons pour pour ne
pas se sentir en sécurité quand tu dis
la tour montré en b3 c'est pour pouvoir
coulisser sur la troisième rangée voyez
venir très rapidement porté donc une
attaque supplémentaire sur le roc noir
oui c est ce qu on appelle une tour
nouveau lot ni du nom du joueur italien
donc je ne sais pas je ne sais pas d'où
ça vient exactement je ne sais pas quand
est-ce qu'il jouait mais en tout cas les
tours sur la troisième rangée comme ça
c'est les toits en wallonie donc très
dangereux qui arrive très vite en
attaque à grand potentiel d'attac examen
est tout à fait donc fou pranger 5 vous
plongez cinq normales on élimine un
attaquant c'est tout à fait logique fou
projet 5 donc la même problème encore
pour les noirs s'ils veulent prendre ce
fou h plongé de 5 c sanctionnait
toujours par le guardian has en achète
le maton h tête et la pique est
maintenant va solide va consolider la
position de ses pièces il joue faux
bessette en d5 tout à fait logique mais
enfin ça paraît quand même bizarre que
dans cette position où les blancs en
tout pour l'attaqué
il sécurise leur fougue du quasiment là
ils sécurisent leurs fous alors je pense
clairement que l'idée est d'éviter un
coup comme tour bien en b3 c'est à dire
d'éviter cette fameuse tour qui montrent
la tour voilà je pense que c'est pour
moi c'était les lâchers ccd contrôler la
casse v3 pour éviter que les blancs
renforcent leur attaque qui est déjà
très virulente
voilà donc ici on arrive dans la
position la plus critique la plus
compliquée de la partie celle qui a fait
l'objet de polémiques puisque on se
demande si vlad a raté un gain dans
cette position ou pas on ne sait pas en
tout cas il ya trois possibilités
analysés pour les experts font acheter
un fou et 6 et le couple ladislav qui
est dépensé 5
alors on va commencer donc on va aller
regarder rapidement puisque c'est quand
même le moment clé de la partie
vladislav à jouer puis on prend pions en
c5
ici on est 20e coup pour les blancs au
28e coublanc possibilité fourrage six
franchises coup très logique sacrifice
de destruction qu'on appelle ça comme ça
détruisant la position noir donc la
reprise est quasiment forcé et
maintenant on joue des matches 5 36 avec
une menace
très violente évident donc sur le sur la
case h c'est cela la case h c'est donc
comment éviter le matin vite cette
position il se voit peut-être un coup
comme f5 f5 c'est la seule solution
alors on peut mentionner également un
autre coup comme tour en 1 8
là je vais montrer ses variantes là
parce qu'elles sont typiques de toutes
les attaques qui se passe avec dame est
fou les sacrifices de destruction sur le
roc et si on se fait mater par un thème
le fameux m'attend quatre fois cet échec
rouages suite fort c'est fou j'ai six
échecs et cher qu'on fait une sorte de
pont du let mais en fait on s'est
rapproché du roi noir très important
puisque maintenant après ranger 8
damache cet échec trois fuites et
maintenant le fou angers si ce n'est
plus en d3 il est en jeu ici justement
qui permet d'un point cet échec et mat
donc ça c'est une petite variante qu'on
peut voir donc dans cette position-là
déplacer la tour n'est pas une solution
pour éviter le mat
la seule solution c'est de jouer le coup
à fond et f5 effectivement il a il ya
peut-être une prise en passant là il ya
la prise en passant qui est donc la
fameuse règle aux cinq tremplins f6 et
sinon il ya les chèques perpétuelle tout
simplement l'échec perpétuelle qui ce
qui consisterait à jouer dan g6 échec au
roi h 8 et on recommence damages six
échecs orages évite donc la lune v noirs
n'ont pas d'autre choix que de répéter
les coups et les blancs peuvent le faire
donc les blancs aurait eu au moins le
nul dans cette position là d'accord en
fait ils ont effectivement une forte
attaque ils ont l'initiative et ce
sacrifice de pièces est quelque chose de
très très très très dangereux il faut
pouvoir tenir avec un roi qui est
complètement éventé qui est à l'air
alors qu'il y encore effectivement plein
de pièces angelier encore mon le fou la
dame de tours dont des tours qui peuvent
monter très rapidement porté le l'assaut
final c'est là qu'on voit effectivement
la pointe de ce fou en dessin et qui
sait que la tour justement en biens ne
peut plus passer pour aider la dame dans
cette question là donc ici à priori
partie nulle obligatoire puisque si on
donne deux coups au noir ils ont quand
même une pièce de plus bien ils vont
réussir à organiser la défense a gagné
la partie
donc ça c'est la première possibilité
rappelons le 21e ou fonds investissent
donc vous prend 1,6 amènerait une
position
nulle en moins pour les blancs au moins
un nul pour les blancs avec des
perspectives d' attaque mais à mon avis
est simplement aussi les bons et c'est
de jouer ils vont perdre la partie donc
probablement une probable autre
possibilité alors là qui est recommandée
par le second dans de jean lieu de
jean-luc chavanon j'ai à dire le second
dans de vladislav tkachiev donc morte à
kashkal eev un nom assez difficile à
prononcer c'est le coup j'ai cinq ans m6
mais alors là les variantes sont
extrêmement compliqué ça part dans tous
les sens ça aboutit à une finale avec un
point de plus pour les blancs donc pour
les vraiment fan de ceux de cette
position de cette partie vous pouvez
aller sur le site de cannes échecs
www.camera et check point org pour avoir
les analyses détaillées de mokhtar kalem
et est ce que tu viens de dire est loi
est quand même particulièrement
intéressant dans le sens où tu nous dis
que vian 21e coup on arrive dans une
position que et bien que le second dans
de vladislav tkachiev à analyser très
très très très loin mais il analysé
après la partie nicolas il ne l'a pas
l'analyser avant cette finale khalij de
drogue de laboratoire non absolument pas
ici c'est une c'est une impro ils ont
analysé ça après la partie donc ici
position voilà très très compliqué après
fou en d5 vladislav joue le 21e coup
critique des princes et 5
donc là on va regarder rapidement ce qui
ce qui s'est passé cavalier prend pion
aux 5
il fallait choisir l'option qu'on allait
prendre on prend qui ont centrale donc
là une fois de plus quand un choix se
présentent
aller toujours vers le centre donc on a
pris confiance entre hal et puis l'a
finalement dont les noirs se sont
débarrassés du pion qui tu es vraiment
très embêtant 5
le cavalier
on a l'impression qu'il va revenir pour
la défense est ce que les noirs sont en
train de remonter petit à petit la pente
alors ici clairement quand on jette un
coup d'oeil de cette position on se dit
les blancs sont perdus et blanc vont
perdre cette partie pourquoi simplement
parce qu une double menace et le
cavalier de 5 qui attaquent le foot est
roi et le pion à ch tis qui attaquent le
fou g5 donc ça ça fait de menaces et
comme on un coup on va pouvoir
rassemblement de paris qu'une menace il
restera un problème
et moi j'en vois une troisième puis ce
qui est encore le pian c5 qui est
également attaqué oui alors l'option c5
c'est un problème d'ordre disons mineur
puisque les autres c'est des pièces pour
ses 5 ce n'est qu'un pion après tout on
peut le sacrifier sa classe une pièce
c'est plus délicat donc ici après
qu'elle prend 1,5 évidemment vladislav
avait envisagé cette possibilité ne
s'est pas laissé surprendre et il joue
au 22e ou fonds investissent continuons
à mettre le feu sur l'échiquier
alors ici avec une justement un nouveau
thème de maths encore c'est cette partie
est très didactique puisque ça laisse
les deux fois en prise et on va voir
qu'on ne peut en prendre
enfin pour en prendre un l'autre n'est
carrément pas prenable
alors j'ai pris 6 c'est possible de
jouer son option g7 qui prend le x 6
mais simplement là la dame blanche
viendrait prendre le canadien aux 5 avec
égalité matérielle puisqu'après d'un
procès qui aurait plus que quatre pions
chacun mais le roi noir serait un peu
détruit c'est à dire qu'ils auraient
deux blocs d'options un peu éloigné un
peu dispersés tout simplement ça serait
pas bon alors là tu la variante superbe
c'est ça c'est qu'il prend des trois
épreuves et prend des trois dames h5
angers 5 menaçant le matin g7 en
menaçant échec et mat
ici le pion g7 est cloué qui veut dire
que s'il prend il ne peut pas prendre le
fou quand tu es le roi se retrouvre
emprise et comme il ne peut pas le
défendit obligé finalement de le pousser
voilà on ne peut pas défendre se purger
sept il faut l'avancé c'est la seule
défense et le coup g7 g6 et maintenant
on est vraiment dans le thème de l'
attaque de maths d'alger 56 menace
d'alger sept matches imparable
voilà c'est simple on ne peut plus
éviter ce match angers c'est donc là
c'est encore très thématique c'est le
mat sur cases noires on peut l'appeler
comme ça
dan g5 menaces matongé 7 obligé de jouer
g6 donc effet lissant encore plus les
cases noires et la dame f6 on arrive et
c'est matt donc là depuis
depuis quelques coups des germes est
passé d'une position ferme et à une
position complètement ouvert puis ce
sont des thèmes de maths de positions
vertes que tu nous montre là oui oui
tout à fait il ya une transformation de
la position depuis simplement qui a eu
cet échange des concessions cavalli
prend 1,5
il ya deux pions qui sont échangées au
centre ça a changé complètement le
caractère de la position alors
maintenant nous continuons la défense
trouvé par jérôme piquette cfcf 5 dans
cette position c'est simplement ça s'est
prémuni contre d'alger 5 qui est joué
quand même par vladislav alors qu'est ce
que ça apporte et comparer la position
de précédentes
c'est simplement cette septième rangée
qui maintenant est disponible donc pour
une défense avec dams et 7 par exemple
cris a été joué et pourquoi pas un coup
comme tour en sept pour permettre à la
dame d'aller peut-être sur une meilleure
case puisque la bon elle ne fait que
défendre un pion tour f7 apparemment été
également possible il n'y a pas de
réponse
arrêtez je dirais sur cette question
peut-être que les noirs on vide de
prendre deux d'aller en belgique pour
prendre la colonne voilà ça ça peut être
une explication effectivement là ils ont
réussi à lier leur tour donc là tu fais
les questions et les réponses
effectivement maintenant on a les deux
tours qui sont interconnectés défendu
mutuellement ça c'est une bonne chose
c'est une chose qu'on a envie de faire
dans toutes les parties civiles adjoint
un petit coussin pas 24e coup l'option
s'inquiètant condamné il avançant ses
six pour comment dire désorganisés les
pièces noires pourquoi donc à une menace
très simple la tourbe est un qui vient
en bessette avec effets dévastateurs
donc ce n'est pas acceptable il faut
prendre ce pion c6 on ne peut pas le
prendre à la dame puisqu'ils auraient
mat avec lecavalier
on se ferait cloud et peut-être résultat
on prend avec le fou 25e coup d'alger 3
donc la ccc bon c'est une partie très
compliqué c'est difficile de la
commenter rapidement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à dire
la menace ici c'est clairement fou h61
f4 donc en fait le cavalier cloué sur la
dame
le cavalier est cloué puisque la dame c7
n'est pas protégé si lecavalier bouge
la dame blanche angers 3 viendra prendre
la dame noire
donc ce clouage compensent largement le
pion qui a été donné en 6,6 ce oui oui
c'est une des idées
effectivement c'est qu'on a tous et le
fond ces six maintenant se retrouve dans
une position instable et il ya toujours
égalité matérielle donc a priori ici
avantage blanc puisque la paire de fou
c'est quand même un facteur important de
foot entre fous et cavaliers c'est mieux
et la piquette trouve une petite astuce
assez amusante il joue le coup f5 f4 les
blancs n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
prendre ce option avec le fou puisque si
la dame rouge à ce moment là le pion g7
prendre à la fois justice mais sera plus
clou il y avait des cloches dans tous
les sens qui semble pas mal pour les
blancs puisque de toute façon ils
avaient l'intention d'installer un fou
sur la case f4 oui oui ça semble pas mal
faut pour un f4 mais là sauf que là il
ya une différence c'est que maintenant
il ya que deux pions f5 donc la colonne
s'est ouverte ce qui permet à la torah
fuite de venir prendre le frais 4
d'ailleurs c'est la partie ben voyons ça
ce que ça
ce que ça nous donne pour preuve 42.4
est obligatoire
cavani f3 échec alors là en fait on
était clos et effectivement la dame
noire se retrouvant prises mais il ya
une priorité plus importante pour les
blancs c'est leur droit
donc ils sont obligés de trouver une
défense pour le roi ils ne peuvent pas
prendre la dame ans s est donc ici en
fait c'est bien c'est une sorte de
découverte et est-ce qu'on peut dire que
bien que piquet avait prévu la vente du
pion ces six avaient prévu cette
position sur l'échiquier
alors là c'est difficile à dire parce
que connaissant les deux joueurs ils ont
dû avoir des problèmes de zeitz note
c'est à dire plus beaucoup de temps
quand on n'a plus que deux minutes pour
jouer dix coups en général on ne calcule
pas cinq coups à l'avancé si on calcule
un ou deux coups à l'avancé bien c'était
un sans faire de grosses fautes en ayant
un plan positionnelle et en même temps
en n'oubliant pas les variantes simple
c'est déjà beaucoup
vladislav katché a fait très fort à ce
petit jeu on l'appelle mister big sea
joue très vite et très bien ici la
variante ça fait bien longtemps qu'elle
ait commencé ça fait cinq coups ils ont
peut-être envisager les deux je ne sais
pas en tout cas la position finale est
très compliqué après calais hier soir il
faut jouer dame prend cavaliers fou
grand dam geipan dame là on arrive donc
dans une position qui a complètement
changé mais vraiment complètement
puisque les blancs ont une date de moins
tout simplement
les noirs ont damé tour contre dont deux
tours est un fou a priori les noirs sont
mieux matériellement les noirs sont bien
dans cette position en tout cas c'est la
vie que j'ai eu en regardant cette
partie et les deux derniers coups de la
partie on va regarder tourner
it fous ces quatre deux derniers coups
de la partie faussée qu'après la des
joueurs font nul alors je pense que
match nul donc ça veut dire un demi
point pour chacun je pense que sa
demande comme une expliquer ça peut
paraître surprenant puisque on a
l'impression qu'ils encore du potentiel
cette partie les blancs attaque un pion
d'un autre côté les noirs ont l'avantagé
matériel alors pourquoi une nulle dans
une position dans une position encore
compliqué a priori la position a l'air
compliqué personnellement je me suis
bien penchés sur le problème et j'ai pas
trouvé de solution simple pour les
blancs de démontrer qu'ils allaient
faire nul alors bon comment on fait nul
dans ce genre de positions qui sont a
priori un peu difficile à évaluer
il ya deux solutions soit on trouve des
menaces suffisante pour arriver une
répétition de coûts c'est à dire qu'on
attaque un pion il le défend on en
attaque un autre il faut qu'il revienne
avec les richesses les défendre et on
repart sur la taille du suivant ça c'est
une possibilité pour faire nul l'autre
possibilité c'est de faire ce qu'on
appelle une forteresse
c'est à dire je mets mes pièces comme ça
et maintenant je joue mon roi n'importe
où je m'en fous les pièces adverse ne
peuvent pas de l'évier s'exerce ne
peuvent pas passer ça c'est la deuxième
solution mais ici j'ai trouvé aucune
explication ni une répétition de coups
ni une forteresse donc a priori mon
analyse c'est que les noirs ont des
bonnes chances de guerre dans cette
position alors les noirs ont des bonnes
chances de gain dans cette position et
pourtant et pourtant parties nulles est
ce que le s que l'aspect psychologique à
quelque part
eu son rôle à jouer dans cette position
à ce stade de la partie
oui je pense que c'est l'explication
l'explication de du résultat les blancs
ont dominé cette partie c'est
indiscutable ils ont eu des bonnes
chances d'attac une belle attaque
d'après morte à kashkal eev après fou et
6 il aurait pu arriver dans une finale
avec un clown plus c'est à dire ils sont
dominés ils ont attaqué ils ont bien
joué
tout s'est bien passé quand tout d'un
coup la position noire a commencé à
ressurgir à revenir après cette faute
dépensé 5 et les noirs se retrouvent
mieux mais en fait quand on quand on a
été mal tout le temps sous pression en
train de chercher des défenses précise
pour pas se faire mater on a beaucoup de
mal à revenir dans l'état d'esprit du
winner de celui qu'ils peuvent gagner la
partie
donc finalement on a souffert toute une
partie on a réussi à sortir la tête de
l'eau
et puis et puis là bon finalement on a
égalisé un peu plus qui égaliser mais on
est tellement content d'en être arrivé
là que le résultat nul finalement
convient le résultat nul convient et en
plus probablement il ya eu un problème
de saïx note c'est à dire que les
joueurs étaient mal autant et si
difficile de dire si les noirs vont
réussir à défendre l'option aux 6 au
premier coup d'oeil le cas aussi ce qui
est là qui est leur leurs faiblesses
donc il ya probablement eu du doute sur
l'évaluation réelle de la position mais
je pense qu'en font les joueurs devaient
tous les deux ça voir que les noirs sont
mieux dans cette position mais piqué qui
était sous pression toute la partie
s'est dit bon là c'est bien j'ai réussi
à maîtriser un peu mon adversaire
on va faire une deuxième nul j'avais les
noirs dans cette partie c'est pas un
mauvais résultat
donc c'est ça va est ce qu'on peut dire
également puisque la partie s'est
arrêtée au 30e coup peut-être que les
joueurs était dans un sale note effréné
dans une position encore riche en
possibilités avec une pendule qui tourne
et qui qui tourne très rapidement
peut-être qu'il était plus sage
peut-être que les noirs étaient un peu
moins bien la pendule se sont peut-être
également d'autres explications qui
pourrait expliquer ce résultat
oui c'est vrai que des de temps en temps
on a tendance à compenser une mauvaise
position par un avantage à la pendule
est donc là on fait une sorte de marché
c'est une sorte de marchandage de tapis
d'épicerie c'est à dire au bon je te
donne trois cacahuètes est une donne en
mars
c'est ça en gros je suis mal apposition
mechner la pendule
donc il ya des chances que tu fasses des
fautes mais si t'en fais pas je m'en
trouver mal donc nul et nul est donc là
c'est effectivement c'est une solution
c'est une solution comme une décision
commune
alors j'ai peut-être elle est peut être
un peu loin mais bon on s'aperçoit que
piquet qui était mal dans le début de la
partie a ressurgi et puis finalement est
arrivé dans une position meilleure et
pourtant ils avaient des noirs
psychologiquement ça a dû être très dur
pour vladislav après cette partie
puisque bon avec les blancs il a eu un
avantage il a gâché et la partie
suivante il avait les noirs et il a
perdu
m oui ça c'est effectivement une
possibilité ce qui s'est passé dans
cette partie clairement ça a dérapé
c'est à dire que il avait le contrôle de
la position il comprenait bien tout ce
qui se passait et ont dû choix au nom de
cette fameuse position il y avait le
choix entre foot champions footsie
soutien au français 5 c'est la position
qui est vers le vers le 20e coup là
c'était il a basculé
il est parti dans des variantes trop
loin trop lointaine trop compliqué il ça
il n'y a pas réussi à reprendre sur lui
la position tout d'un coup lui a explosé
au visage il a été surpris par les
veines la tournure des événements et ça
ça a dû un peu le déstabiliser il a on
perd en confiance c'est à dire que ça
explose et complètement il alors qu'ils
s'y attendait pas il pensait garder
contrôlé alors que il a perdu environ
et ça c'est effectivement difficile et
bien une partie très riche en
enseignements
autant d'un point de vue éthique et un
que d'un point de vue effectivement et
qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans la
tête des joueurs
la semaine prochaine nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir très fortement sur
cet événement majeur notamment avec le
gain qu'on a pu voir des vladislav
aujourd'hui est également un come back
sur sur le gain de piquer donc lors de
la troisième partie
je te prends pas si tu veux bien
d'attaquer la troisième rubrique ce soir
qui est consacré donc à l'actualité
internationale avec deux événements de
taille deux événements importants qui
est notamment le championnat de jeunes
qui s'est déroulé à pau et puis si tu
veux bien nous nous attaquons également
un petit peu au match kasparov cram nick
qui fait beaucoup beaucoup de bruit et
qui défoule les passions oui oui tout à
fait alors je sais pas donc pas où on
commence vers ce match a commencé
commençons par le match kasparov
cramique le match a lieu en octobre
et quelque chose me surprend un petit
peu parce que me semblait que le match
au début devait se jouer contre kasparov
a non des puis il ya eu quelques petits
bouleversements
as tu eu quelques petites explications à
nous fournir par rapport à ça oui disons
kasparov cherche un challenger depuis
maintenant cinq ans c'est à dire qu'en
95 il a joué à nantes et depuis n'a pas
remis son titre en jeu donc qu'à ce
moment fait la recherche d'un challenger
est prêt à tout pour
comment dire pour cautionner son titre
de champion du monde puisqu'il n'est
plus au sein de la fédération
internationale des échecs il a créé sa
propre fédération en fait son propre
titre personnel il cherche un adversaire
il a proposé au vainqueur du match
shirov chronique de jouer contre lui
si on va gagner le match n'a pas eu lieu
ensuite il a proposé un nombre de jouer
contre lui avant d'accepter le match n'a
pas eu lieu toujours pour des questions
diverses et variées notamment des
sponsors qui se désistait ou des
contrats
me ou des organisations qui dérape et
hélas il semblerait bien avec cette fois
ci on soit arrivé au match de kasparov
organisé par le les olympiades des
sports de l'esprit donc l'association
mon association ou entreprise je ne sais
pas dirigée par raymond quine le grand
maître d'échecs
apparemment ils ont trouvé les fonds les
contrats sont signés et donc on va enfin
avoir le champion du monde garry
kasparov le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps mais bonjour actuelle clairement
peut-être le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps qui va jouer un match contre
vladimir kramnik numéro deux mondial
alors effectivement dans un premier
temps c'était shirov qui était pressenti
pour ce match puis finalement ça n'a pas
pu se réaliser
ensuite nous avions à nantes
pareillement parlera pas de casque au
mais le match n'a pas pu se réaliser
également et maintenant cramique est-ce
que j'ai l'impression que finalement les
sponsors sont pas très n'était pas très
convaincu par par shirov ou par allende
est ce que aujourd'hui on a du mal à
organiser un tel match parce que il ya
un problème de légitimité c'est quoi est
ce que tu peux nous nous éclairer sur ce
sujet alors mon avis des problèmes déjà
effectivement ce n'est plus au sein de
la fidh et la fédération internationale
des échecs qui organise un championnat
du monde avec une centaine de joueurs
venus du monde entier qui est très bien
qu'ils aient un système élimination
directe mais qui ressemble plus à une
loterie cas un vrai tournoi qui
détermine qui est le meilleur joueur du
monde deuxième problème
kasparov est trop fort c'est à dire que
voilà pour parler vulgairement qui va
payer pour voir un pauvre malheureux se
faire exploser par garry kasparov
voilà la situation où on en est
actuellement malheureusement c'est que
kasparov chaque fois qu'il joue un
tournoi il gagne avec énormément de
points d'avancé pourtant il a perdu
compliquées récemment il a perdu mais
cette idée un parti exhibition en semi
rapides personnes donc personne était
invincible
personne n'était invincible lève quand
même kasparov il à 2850 le deuxième à
2750 et à ce niveau là les 100 points il
faut vraiment aller les chercher c'est
vraiment 100 points qui valent très cher
très cher en temps au niveau de jeu en
investissement tout ce que vous voulez
en tout cas c'est un écart de niveau qui
est vraiment exceptionnel étant que
kasparov n'aura pas dix ans de plus
on a du mal à lui trouver un adversaire
à son niveau wallon sinon il faut que
les jeunes progressent mais il va
falloir soit que kasparov fatigue soit
que les jeunes pers
voilà parmi les jeunes on à etienne
bacrot notre star nationale il ya
ruslans ponomariov qui arrive qui est
jeune et qui à 2610 souvent déjà qui est
le plus grand maître de tous les temps
mais pour les jeunes grands maîtres de
nos jeunes grands maîtres de tous les
temps et en tous cas donc
rappelons quand même ce tournoi de
sarajevo où va participer entre autres
garry kasparov vladimir kramnik michael
adams enfin il y aura beaucoup de top
plus etienne bacrot donc ce sera la
première confrontation entre gary et
étienne et ça ça va être un très beau
tournoi sarajevo d'accord donc match et
kasparov kramnik en octobre un événement
que diagonale va suivre dix mois et loi
shirov n'avait-il pas gagné contre
chronique en match shirov est très très
fort en match il a gagné tous les
matches qu'il a joués et ça aurait pu
être un adversaire intéressant pour rire
et kasparov
travnik en match est beaucoup moins
forme chronique en match est beaucoup
moins fort c'est-à-dire qu'il a faits
récemment donc quelques matchs et
quelles ont été ses résultats sur ces
matches à bien il est je pense qu'il les
a tous perdus la peur du pont de
galfingue enfin il a battu new dassine
c'est le premier match qu'il a joué
d'être sa 5 ou 6 ans pendant sept ou
huit
il ya très longtemps ensuite il a perdu
contre belfort il a perdu contre kamski
et il a perdu contre shirov récemment tu
es en train de nous dire que le numéro
deux mondial a quelques petits problèmes
en match oui c'est ce qu'on disait en
début d'émission c'est à dire que le
match et le tournoi c'est pas du tout
pareil
vladimir kramnik en tournoi est vraiment
le numéro deux mondial en match par
contre
n'est pas du tout n'est même pas dans le
top 5 mondial probablement et bien un
match à suivre avec grand intérêt nous
aurons l'occasion de revenir sur cet
événement de nombreuses fois si vous le
voulez bien nous allons passer
maintenant au championnat de france qui
se sont déroulés à pau alors on peut
donner quelques résultats si tu veux
bien et lois en ce qui concerne les
pupilles donc c'était je pense cette
année particulièrement relevé oui je
pense que c'est en pupilles justement
que se trouve la relève la relève des
échecs français en tout cas puisqu'ils
sont assez fort il ya donc maxime
vachier lagrave ce qui est très très
fort qui à 2200 déjà qu'un jeune
parisien qui est très fort il
edouard bonnet qui est également très
fort puisqu'il avait gagné le
championnat de france poussins ou petit
poussin et 9 sur 9
c'est un tueur il joue très bien il ya
aussi fera de marquer ce qui n'est pas
mal non plus donc en pupilles à trois
jeunes qui valent à peu près de 1200
points elo ce qui est ce qui est pas mal
du tout à cet âge là en benjamins je
crois qu'il est quelque chose d'assez
intéressant également avec la victoire
d'une jeune fille la victoire d'une
fille dans la catégorie mixte c'est tout
à fait exceptionnel ils m'ont mais la
personne est également exceptionnel
semmaris au bac qu'on a reçues en
diagonale qui joue très très bien qu'ils
jouent vraiment très très bien et qui a
donc gagné ce championnat de france
benjamins très bien en minimes
je crois qu'on a deux joueurs de
oui en minimes c'est le duo le duo
sébastien mazet sébastien plante et qui
remporte le tournoi
ces deux jeunes espoirs formé à cali ça
c'est un cas et ça c'est le club qui a
su former des champions puisque à pisser
la lautié ils sont tous passés par
khaisor olivier rené également sont tous
passés par là et là malheureusement le
club a quelques problèmes en ce moment
mais espérons que ça sera vite résolu il
ya une petite pensée pour le club de
kaïs aquitain club au combien mythique
j'espère que les choses s'arrangeront en
ce qui concerne la catégorie reine la
catégorie junior oui et c'est robert
fontaine qui a gagné cette année encore
un jeune qui a été plus ou moins formés
à kayes ça va robert fontaine donc
affinium finalement eu cette
consécration en juniors ça fait
longtemps qu'on l'attendait qu'on
l'attendait là cette année il est
vraiment champion de france junior
devant guillaume valin qui avait gagné
le tournoi accession du championnat de
france en juniors c'est un peu moins
fort qu'avant mais il joue quand même
pas mal mais il faut quand même très
bien et bien la relève s'annonce
prometteuse je te propose maintenant de
parcourir très rapidement les autres
donc thèmes de l'actualité on peut
annoncer une nouvelle en ce qui concerne
bent larsen bent larsen le joueur danois
que je connaissais tout ce qui a marqué
son époque l'époque de fisher de galère
et c'est qui
malheureusement quelques problèmes de
santé donc on espère un prompt
rétablissement
donc on pense on pense tous à toi ben
t'as vraiment toi bien & remets toi vite
également un événement important qui
commence qui a commencé aujourd'hui le
tournoi donc de deux raids bus avec
michael adams john spillmann avec tony
mal et puis et puis mur et que vous
connaissez tous y'a comme youri qui est
nôtre notre artiste français puisque
c'est lui qui fait les préparations les
plus compliqués qui a été le second dans
le corps je paye donc un très beau
tournoi redbus je pense qu'on a fini
pour cette actualité
on en termine là si vous voulez bien
donc merci à tous de nous avoir suivi la
semaine prochaine on réattaque avec
l'événement qui marquera la semaine qui
le match 4 h pique et merci à tous au
revoir
oh
l oms